hey y'all it's andrew couch here and in
this tight tuesday video we're going to
be going over the per
package so this is going to be the final
installment of my
intro to the tiger series and i consider
per to be
the more advanced package from the
tigerverse because it
basically relies on functions and
functional programming
so if you don't have a good
understanding or a good
amount of experience with functions in r
uh you might want to check out my video
on functions
um but for this video i'm probably gonna
go pretty
beginner friendly with what i'm gonna do
with per just so you guys can get a
basic understanding of what we can do
with it
um recently i've noticed that i've had
some audio issues in my past videos
i'm not really sure why because i just
use obs uh and
mostly plug and play uh i don't also
change anything so
i went back to my obs settings and it
basically just converted them to default
settings so hopefully the audio issue
was solved i'm not really sure what was
going on
because i don't really change obs not
only that but i haven't really been on
my desktop for a few weeks so
um hopefully that'll fix everything but
um we'll see
so i'm gonna open up my season two
project
uh and we're gonna load in a an r
markdown document
and i'm gonna call this like uh a brief
overview of her
um i'm also gonna basically go over the
the main functions of her but with per
itself there aren't a lot of functions
that goes actually into it
so if we go to the reference we can see
it basically goes
around the mapping function
so the map function um we have a lot of
variants
we have map2 map2lgl or logical
map2int but what map really is
is just a for loop so if we want to
iterate through
a list or a data frame we can use the
map
mapping function to basically be a nice
little
helper function for your traditional for
loops
i never use for loops in r anymore
um i always go with mapping which is the
more tidier way to do it
but um i think if you're doing a lot of
development for packages
you might still stick with the uh the
four whoops
with the actual map families um you can
see how with map you have
map logical character and um these
things
are basically saying what we want to
we're specifying what we actually want
to return
so with map that's your overall like you
don't really want to you're not
specifying what you're returning
so it could be a data frame a number a
character
a chart whatever but if you want to be
more specific so you don't have to do
any cleaning
you can say like map integer if you're
going to return like a number
or map double if you know you're going
to return a double
map dfr and map dfc are data frames and
you're basically just
saying it whether it's a row or a column
and then we have our map variants which
are map2
and pmap i don't really use imap at all
or
lmap but i mostly use map2 or pmap
and although they seem a little bit more
confusing
or a little bit more advanced it's just
passing in another
argument so with map2 we're passing in
two arguments
with pmap or more uh passing in multiple
arguments
so we can use as many arguments as we
want but we'll go over that
right now
okay so with the tidy verse um when we
load in the tigers we already have the
per
package and generally when i'm
when i was first learning per i didn't
really understand
when to use per right so with per i just
would always assume i would use a mutate
instead of a mapping function because
if we're going to go through an entire
list and do some type of transformation
um it doesn't really make any sense to
use per or to use map over mutate right
so if i want to say
i want to take uh the square root of
sepal length
i'll just say square root
people link is equal to
sequel dot length and we're just going
to do a basic square
root and that does it that essentially
went through the entire list
um and returned the square root of the
value
one of the things that we have to
realize though is that the square root
function is vectorized so we can
actually pass through
a vector whereas with map it doesn't
need to be vectorized
but if we want to do the same thing so
we can say map square root
we can just pass in the map function
map and in this case we're basically
saying that we have a data frame and
we're going to pass
a column as a list so let's say
sepal length and then what we need to do
is call in
the function which would be square roots
and we can see we have
um this little double and if we look at
right here we can see that it actually
returned a list
so with per it's always when we turn our
list but luckily
we can do a few things for one thing i
can always say
unnest and i'll just basically unlist
e values but since we know that we're
doing a square root we can also say map
dbl and i'll pass in uh
it'll just automatically unnest it and
pass in the that single value
there's a few issues you might run into
with per
so one thing that you might run into is
uh
is you might have multiple lengths of a
list so if we just do this
um we might see sometimes where we'll
have like two items in this
list and that will be something where
you have to basically adjust the
function
or be able to just unnest it and
understand that you might have some
repeats
um what's also kind of interesting is
let me see
um is that we can actually pass in
multiple arguments
with our mapping function so in this
case we can say
map
right so we can pass in this
so we have that um in this case i'll
probably just do
log and with log we have these
other arguments with base exp1 um i
think we can say like
uh log say let's say 10
base equal to like three right
so in that case we can say a map and a
log
and we can just type in base is equal to
three
and i'll pass in um
that function's second argument so
there are many ways we can actually pass
in arguments using map
um i would advise using
i would try to use the simpler mapping
function so when i mean simpler i mean
instead of using uh map2 or in this case
if i were to
want to pass in a base three i would say
i mutate
base is equal to three and then i would
say mutate
map square root is equal to map
two and with map two we can see we have
a dot x and dot y
and that is essentially our first and
second inputs and then our function
so in this case we'd say sepal dot
length
uh base and then we can say like log
um and if we do map2dbl
we can see we have the same same thing
right
um as you can see this is still kind of
confusing because
we at the end of the day we probably
wouldn't be doing it like this
additionally it's going to be a little
bit slower because essentially we're
going to go through
you know the list um and it's not
vectorized so
what we can think about is what are the
actual use cases for map
um one of the things that i would uh i
like to show people
is com combining it with its other
functions
from the titeverse so i mentioned in my
other tigers videos is we actually have
a
a nest function which is part of the
tidy r package
um what we can do though is essentially
nest
um everything by species so in this case
we're creating
three data frames where each data frame
represents
the species uh data and what we can do
is we can pass in this data since this
data is a list
into a function um one of the things
that we can think about
is creating like a bunch of models um
so this is probably a pretty simple
approach but we can say we want to make
a model
and it is equal to map data
and then we have to have a passive
function in this case we can say we can
use a tilde
or we can type in dot f is equal to
function
and give it our little argument um or we
can just write a function and that'll
just automatically do it
so we can do this um we'll just do it
all three ways
so in this case i'll just say we'll do
the first quick way
in case we're having a simpler function
in this case it'll be like that
uh we can say like uh we'll just predict
i don't know
sepal length uh sure yeah sepal length
using
people.with
uh with plus petal.length
plus petal
with and then we have to pass on our
data which
is equal to dot x right so what we
basically did was we created
three models for each species
right um and now what we can actually do
is i'm actually loading another helpful
package
which is the broom package which allows
us to basically tidy these models
so let's select the species and model
and if we actually un-nest these models
since this is a
s3 like lm object we can see that it
gets a little weird because
it says the input must be a list of
vectors
because we can't really return all these
models because it's not the right class
that we want
um there are a lot of ways we can do
this so we can say like you know maybe
we'll like pull the model
or something like that and we can see
how okay we have these three
um summaries of earlier models but
that's not really clean
um we can't really do anything with it
we can't plot it out
um and it's kind of hard to see because
you can see how it's in a list right now
um luckily we have the broom package
and what we can do is we can actually do
another mapping function and this is
where we know that
you know it kind of doesn't make any
sense that we'd pass in on our model
from a mutate um it just wouldn't work
so if we say model equals
uh tidy model
we can see that there's no tidying
method recognized for this
list right so we'd have to like extract
that model from
all from the from the data frame so what
we'd have to do is like we'd have to
select this model
put it into our tidy function and then
extract the actual results
um and if you think about that we're
essentially
wanting to go through the list
sequentially or just like
one by one pass pass that model into a
function
and then return our coefficients in our
summary statistics of the model
so when we think of stuff where we know
we can't really use mutate because we're
going to be passing in
a lot of information and also returning
a lot of information
um we want to think about using map so
in this case we can say is
model is equal to or we'll just call
this tidied
a model or id model legal to map
and we want to pass each model into our
tidy function
and there we go we have a tidy model as
a tibble and this in this case we can
just select our
uh we'll select our species and our tidy
model
and now we can actually do is a nest it
and as you can see here we have all of
our coefficients with our terms
estimates p values probably would need
to do um
some analysis we could do some analysis
from there so we could say like
uh ggplot uh
y equals estimate uh color is equal to
species
and then we just say uh like a gm point
right and we can see how these uh
coefficients
um kind of change with with our actual
uh
species and that's pretty useful for a
lot of our stuff
um additionally um what we can do is do
some actual like uh
um we can show you we can show how we uh
tidy models
actually uses um unmapping
which i actually find pretty useful so
generally when we're creating a bunch of
models or for me i'm creating a lot of
forecasts
um i want to have or i want to manage a
lot of models
but i also have to manage a lot of
parameters and with forecasts we're
always going to be
uh we're always going to be uh like
refitting the data
so we can forecast the next um period um
and with
when you're managing a lot of forecasts
you need to kind of manage a lot of
parameters so
often what i'll do is i'll create a grid
of parameters for each model
so let's actually go through here and
make you know
um some type of nested model which like
with like xgboost or something like that
so we'll do that okay
so we have our data right now and what
we want to do basically
is we want to train let's just say a
random forest model
for each species um right so
obviously right now like it maybe won't
won't make too much sense to do it for
species but
you can see if you're you know doing a
lot of forecasting with like a lot of
product data or a lot of um
you know just a lot of like time series
data um where you know that you need to
have an individual forecast for all that
stuff
and this will be essentially what we
would try to start approaching
right so we have our nested data um what
we would probably want to do is create
our testing splits
so i'll create my seed which will be 40
54.
um and then what i'll do is like we'll
create our um
data splits and we'll just map our data
and say initial
in this case we could say prop is equal
to 0.8
and we have our splits and then what we
would want to probably do is our
train data so map data
splits and we'll say training
and then we'll say our test data is map
data
split is testing
and then we could finally create our
final um
uh we can now start thinking about how
we want to create our models
so in this case we actually might want
to try to
um create just a general model for all
of our stuff
so what we can actually pass in is a uh
a model so in this case we'll do um
we'll say our model is equal to um
not even boosted tree um or we'll do a
random forest right random forest and
we'll say
freeze is equal to tune
uh oops must be a vector and then we'll
just like uh
um oh actually i got it i got i have a
better idea
we'll do that and this will be our model
data
right and then what we want to do is
start creating our
um model our models that we want to tune
so in this case we'll do a
rf model so random forest
in this case we want to set our tree our
trees to a
tune uh
probably just going to do a regression
problem and then we'll say set engine to
uh random forest
right and now we wanna do is create a
grid so our rf grid
is a grid regular and we'll give it our
regular and we'll give it our um
random force models parameters
oops parameters
and we have our rf grid um
and then that's basically it uh we'll
we'll also have to start creating a
recipe so we'll start doing that
right here so let's actually create our
recipe so in this case we'll say
mutate recipe is equal to
map train data
train data and in this case we'll do the
different way to create a function in
our map so we'll just see the dot f
is equal to function x
in this case x will be kind of a a proxy
for our train data
and we'll say recipe i will say sepal
dot
length data is equal to x
right so we're not doing any
pre-processing we're just doing we're
basically saying
um what we what our variable we want to
predict with
uh what we want to predict and what we
want to predict with which in this case
we're using um all of the data besides
species to predict
sepal length all right so we have a
recipe
and one thing i also forgot was we need
to get our little k-folds data set
so i'll just say k-folds data
is equal to map and we always pass in
our train data and we'll just say
default cv and we can pass that
right there so oops
so we'll say create k folds and
recipe okay
so now that we have our model data
um we kind of want to pass in uh our
training stuff
right in this case what we want to think
about is we'll say
train bottles and we have to think about
what we want to pass
so in this case we're only passing in
our recipe
and our k-folds data set the rest of the
stuff we're actually just gonna we
already have our mod on our model grid
so we'll just fit to that okay
in this case we'll say tune grid we give
it
our model which is right here our rf
model
we give it our recipe
we give it our red which will be
our rf grid and we'll give it also a
resample so that way you can tune our
parameters with our k-folds data
okay and we have that right there
and now oops now what we can do
is we can pass in our model data
and we can say what we're going to do is
essentially get our tune results so
tune results is equal to map
2 and we're going to be passing in our
recipe which will be right there
and our k folds data
and we're just going to say train models
now what we're doing is basically
training all of our models with one
simple step
right and if we look right here we can
see how per is actually pretty useful
because it makes everything look very
clean it also encourages us to
write our our transformations and all of
our processes into a function
and name it something you know
convenient or informative
you know instead of having that um what
i think is kind of a
not really a great looking um syntax
with four loops so it'd be like four um
i and like one two three one through
three
and going through that and specifying
all that uh we can just use this little
map right there
i'll do it for us okay
so we have our model data um in this
case we
will say you know our parameters
parameters is equal to
map tune results
attune results and we say show
best um show
s rmse i'm gonna see
n equals one
right
right so now we have our parameters
right there
okay um
now that we have our parameters what we
can do is we can actually finalize our
model so we'll say
uh final model is equal to dot
map uh parameters transmitters
and in this case we're gonna pass into a
function
right and what i'll say is we'll have
our
we're going to base pass in our workflow
so our workflow will be
our model and our um our ooh actually
wolf paths in
two which will be our parameters and our
recipe so we will fasten x and y
and then we'll say workflow
add model which would be our rf model
add recipe which will be our recipe
and we'll say finalize workflow
and pass in our uh
parameters right
um f equals function
map two
oh yeah um it's a rf model x add recipe
is y f equals
unexpected symbol
map2 rf model xy finalized
oops it's here so we got that and we'll
say uh
mutate uh final model oops
model goes map2 and we'll get our
parameters
uh and then our recipe
is equal to function x y
um and then workflow
profile add model wrf
model add recipe bry and
finalize work well which will be our
why there we go um lastly what we want
to do is our
we want to do you know our last fit so
let's say um
um eval is equal to map to
final model data splits
and we can say i think we say last split
uh
final our last
split is that what's what
uh oops parsnip
uh was it last uh fit yep there you go
in this case we'll pass in there
um last
bit yep oh and then we have a little
beard
cannot palm trees
oh oh that's why um and then our
parameters is uh
okay and with our final model data what
we can do is
we'll select our species and our eval
oh species
and eval and then what we can say is
mutate metrics
and then map eval collect
metrics and then we can select our
uh we can select our species and our
metrics
and we can unnest those final metrics
oops
okay and as you can see you know we have
pretty good
room mean squared error we we predict a
little bit better
on virginica cool so
that's basically it for you know
generally using mac
uh per with you know tidy models but
we'll actually go into
you know maybe some charts that we want
to do um what i also enjoy doing with
per is mapping out some charts so what
we can do
right is we can nest minus species
and then we can say like i don't know we
can just plot out
a scatter plot so map
data dot f is equal to function x
gdp data equals x um aesthetic is equal
to you know
simple dot length y equals sepal
uh width and we can say like uh
i don't know like a gm point right so
we can return a ggpod object and then we
can say like i nest
i think it's on this chart as a pull
chart yeah we can we can pull the chart
and we can see each um
we can see uh all three of these charts
pretty quickly
so again when we think about this uh we
can kind of get creative with it where
not only do we have to do we not only
can we you know
train a lot of models but we can
basically automate and do a lot of
things in a quick succession
so if i had like a huge report that i
wanted to do for like you know each
manager
and i had like the manager ids with
their respective data that they have to
track um maybe it might be worth it for
me to you know write a little small
little function to you know plot out
you know the general charts that they
want to see or maybe like a table
that they would i want to i would want
to write out so
that's that's basically it for mapping
mapping in general
um we're basically just wrapping around
functions that we think
that would be useful to go through
iteratively instead of a vector
um and basically the good way to think
about it is
if you don't know if map well if you
don't know whether to use map or mutate
try out mapping first if you've uh if
you brought out the function
um and if it gets good results then you
know try to pass it into mutate and then
if it doesn't work in mutate
you can probably rewrite the function
until be vectorized and it will work to
mutate
um but sometimes we run into some issues
where map will return an error
um in this case a lot of the times i use
um
i use a a mapping is with
um with web scraping so if i go to my
ufc sports betting model
um i can show you my
what's your data scraping and we can see
how i wrote basically a bunch of
functions to scrape stuff so to scrape
cards scrape dates
scrape fights stuff like that
um so all these are just put into little
functions
and then what i do is i basically map uh
these scraping functions i map these
scraping functions
so it will scrape the cards go through
each list
or each website link iteratively so
it'll go first to this website
then it'll scrape all this stuff uh and
then go to the next link scrape all the
stuff
and then after that i'll go and you know
use the previous script
stuff or scrape data and then use that
to scrape more stuff
um so yeah so um i think when you're
thinking about like traversing nodes or
you know just doing web scraping
mapping is a good way to kind of uh
organize your thought process
and also organize how you're gonna
approach things too
plus it makes it a little bit cleaner so
instead of having all this stuff
um we can see how this which scrapes
every ufc
fight uh from every card i mean all the
data
it looks pretty clean because it's only
about four functions um
so it's pretty nice like that um i'm
going to also show you
a few useful things that come
not with per but is useful when you're
actually doing using per
um so what we can load in is the
progress package um
and a lot of times when you're running a
long function specifically
a function that takes you know more than
10 minutes where you're not really sure
what's gonna happen
um it's nice to see some progress with
it um
with this when i was scraping it it
would actually take about 20 minutes
when i was scraping all the cards
initially
now since i have a little filter where
i'm only going to scrape cards i haven't
scraped before
um it's a little bit faster but um a lot
of times you might want a progress bar
especially if you're doing like
simulations
so what we can do is use the progress
package
which is made for map um and we
basically say we want to create a
progress bar and that's pb
and then what we can say is like uh
uh pb is like pb uh
what's it uh oops progress bar
and then
new and then total is equal to whatever
we want to do
so for me i'll just do a basic example
so i'll say
uh sim and then i'll say uh
i don't know um we'll uh
uh we'll just say table um x is equal to
seek that ins
one two thousand
so in this case we're gonna say uh we're
gonna have
uh essentially we have to say how many
um iterations we're gonna be doing so we
have to say usually like n row or number
of rows that we're going to simulate
through
in this case now we can just say uh we
would have to write a helper function
so for me i'll just say uh um all
uh um
i'll just return you know generic
function uh function and we'll say x
and we'll say uh x squared right
so if we then do sim and we'll say
mutate
x equals uh and we'll say x equals a map
x and then we'll zoom generic function
um we can see that it'll actually do
that
but we never got a progress bar so what
we can do now is
write in the progress bar and our
generic function so in this case we have
to say pb
pick and syst dot
sleep one over one hundred okay
and when we do that we can see how this
progress bar
is going um area like that
um you may notice that this is actually
slower right now because i'm using the
assist.sleep
i mean reality this is vectorized so um
it's actually making it a little bit
slower
but when you're doing like long scraping
functions or long simulations it's
pretty useful
uh to do that so we can see that past
that
and um and it was uh it was pretty
useful
additionally what we can do is if you're
writing
um you know uh if you if you notice that
per
is a little bit slower than what you
would like you can also
load in the fur package so
the fur package only for package um let
me
show you guys the fur package uh is
basically per
but with parallel processing um and
there's a lot of
and there's a lot of uh things that goes
along with fur that you kind of have to
think about
but generally you know if you're doing a
lot of quick processes
uh it's generally uh useful to use um
parallel processing because they'll
obviously go faster but if you're you
know you're carrying large data frames
around
large model objects um it actually will
be a little bit slower because it can't
really handle all that in
in memory so for me um generally i'll
try using fur but
if i'm also doing like you know stand
models or you know
moving like millions and millions of
rows um through this iteration or
through this
simulation then i'll probably navigate
away from future map
or from the fur package and stick with
the original
per package okay so
um one thing you have to do is you have
to type in the i believe you have to say
your total workers so in this case we'll
do like four since i think i have a
parallel processing with four cores and
what we'll do
is i'll just uh i'll just do a a simple
one with
you know one one two three one two three
one two three
right and we can say is uh and what's a
generic
function uh function
uh always a parallel function
and we'll give it sim and we'll give it
the
square root of uh sim
yep so i'll just uh
kind of benchmark it because i'm
actually kind of curious about it
so systems
this dot time and then what we'll do is
um we'll just do the first
simulation so we'll say um sim
mutate sim map parallel
function and then end
i begin minus cis dot time
uh oops and we'll pass that with them
right and what's kind of funny about
uh and two what's
interesting about uh
um the the fur package right
is that it's simply changing map to
future
map actually you should not put that
many zeros in i'm gonna
um do like one two three
um yeah can i stop that
um oops yeah because i put way too many
zeros that was uh that was a misclick
um and i'll i'll save this to uh tidy
tuesday uh per
i choose it
okay um yeah so we actually don't want
to do like uh
that many
okay
um let's see what else can i do while
this runs a little bit um
and then i can oh yeah i can show also
the
the other function um with
um handling errors um
using the possibly function so with per
there's actually a bunch of um like
helper functions
that can do some error handling too so
if we go back here
and if we go to our reference make sure
this is going down
okay um we can see that there's
some um interesting
um where is it right here so
basically it'll capture some side
effects in this case um usually what
i'll do
is use the possibly function um
there's three main functions safely
quietly quietly and possibly
um safely is pretty good
um generally return like a bunch of uh
two lists
like one with the a value and one with
the return to error message
and then possibly will kind of do the
same thing
but it'll give you it'll force like a
default value
okay let's see here okay maybe i
shouldn't have done this
um i should have just done that i don't
know why i did that
let's see if we can stop this
okay uh no don't determine
i should probably save it just in case
it crashes um generally i
i try to when i use parallel processing
uh i do i do it for more of a
statistical simulations
uh not really for like these little
general square root things
um and also i don't do that many
simulations with it so general it's a
pretty long process already
so i try to stick um with you know a
hundred like when i'm like do
bootstrapping or something like that
um so i would be a little bit wary with
parallel processing just
because it caught for me personally it
causes issues with r
um so let's see if i can get this okay
you know what
okay
oh okay it's gonna probably crash i
guess
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay i'm just going to reopen this um
we'll do tuesday prayer
okay okay here we go
and i'll just do right there
um and i'll just load in the stuff sorry
about that
okay um so we have that and then what we
can do
is i'll just do the 1000
right right there
and then we can see how you know
oh what's it called and
you know we have the exact process and
it's a little bit faster um
okay oh
okay um so one thing that we can do
with um um per is we can show
the uh possibly and safely um in this
case i'll probably just do
uh the possibly so in this case i'll
just do seek
dot int and we'll say minus
uh minus 100 minus uh
one two five right and we'll say x
so if we wanted to take like the log of
this we could say you know
mutate i'm logged equal to map
x and we'll say log
it'll probably return a error right
and um so what we can do is also do a
s uh awesome oops
possibly and then we'll
possibly and then we'll say log
otherwise um we'll just say like a zero
or something like that
uh oh maybe maybe this isn't right
uh the best example but um maybe we can
do a
square root of like and one i'll do that
um but you know you can do some error
handling too so let me see there's a
good example where
um safely log um
oh okay that let's do that um
find rows and we'll say x table
x equals a
oh safely and then we'll say
log a zero
otherwise oops or possibly
does this actually work anymore uh let's
see here
okay it kind of does okay so yeah you
can see how uh
you know we can do some error handling
stuff like that but i personally don't
use it a lot
um so again it's not too useful i only
use it mostly when i'm doing a bunch of
web scraping uh and that in that case
they usually pass in
um a decent amount of errors you know
when there's like a missing link
that just so happens to be like a
deadline or something like that um
so yeah let me see i thought i could get
possibly to work because
okay i guess oh i guess i didn't pass it
in as a list
so that's that's how you do it
so um with that being said uh i hope you
guys enjoyed the video
i know this is pretty quick um and i
went pretty high level over the
functions but
you know once you get used to um per and
his framework and writing functions i
think it's probably one of the more
useful
um packages that is underutilized um and
you know beginner uh data workflows
so um that's the conclusion to the
tidyverse
series um for my next series i'm going
to be focusing more on
um our shiny stuff so i want to go over
our shiny um filtering um our shiny
charts in general
you know how to do files and stuff like
that so uh that'll be an interesting
project
an interesting series so um i'll see you
guys next time and teddy on